why why did you want to go into piracy
what made you want to conduct piracy
work alone I sue the saucer value or
other comforts to me the Erin Condren
wan-koo myself there are enough Walton
anwar al d'amato bangle in the Horn of
Africa the line between fishing and
piracy has long
the first pirates were actually
fishermen turned vigilante
they attacked foreign boats they
believed were fishing illegally in
Somali waters off the Somali coast where
those pirates attacked that vessel
when they realized that they could make
huge profits by holding these boats to
ransom piracy became big business and
Somalia became a no-go zone for
Americans and other Westerners we have
seen a dramatic increase in piracy in
this area and it is a matter of real
concern as a maritime investigator
piracy is my specialty
for over six years I've been doing
hostage negotiations and ransom drops so
if the murder video is connected to
piracy it ought to be a no brainer for
me to prove I Carsten thanks for
agreeing to talk to me can you tell me
why you're here in prison
Diana they might get the van out but
they know call of duty another stage
that kind of oh yeah Karate Kid or do I
know Kirby market back in a backup they
are running away there what the
transitions are they yeah he's a mother
that ERISA of the Somali Aloha Aloha
kiss Robert and for you being a
fisherman do you recognize like a boat
like this
no guarana Allah Allah do damage if
they've done or their family
do you think this person is from Somalia
my does he look Somali Mario Ola myself
: what you want but the guys in that
prison are convicted pirates what's
interesting though is all the deckhands
swear that the victims in the water were
Somali pirates I showed those photos to
actual Somali pirates and they said no
these guys do not look Somali and they
just don't fit the bill
[Music]
you